hey guys so we are about to go on a
little weekend trip but Maddie is
getting real wild and ripping off my
shoelaces we're already three hours late
because of me
Matt is losing his mind over their
actual Matt so is Jenna sure let's talk
about this shirt how many are left
okay well what is this gonna be uploaded
I don't know for a week there's only 500
left so I don't know we'll see John I'm
Matt's video and then a month later
we'll see Justin's preshrunk cotton
though are you sure I'm pretty sure let
me touch it good oh that is nice that's
real nice Maddie did Maddie did you get
your toothbrush it's under the couch
hello I'm in the car for a lot of hours
maybe two we may be here for two hours
why don't we leave us yeah
Maddie's been a good boy though just
sleeping away Justine's been a good girl
just yapping away back here we had to
get Matt food Matt is hungry human Matt
[Music]
well make sure he doesn't
let's take him back come on Jen and I
are gonna go to groceries and get the
girl I can't even talk I'm so exhausted
I was up all night editing I'm gonna
close this door so this is one left okay
well so there's other animals in here
clearly because Maddie's losing his
mother I know my God look at that spider
I mean it's pretty it's pretty cold
we just really gonna pop down to get
some instance where this thing is
Oh Oh like user-friendly really like a
steep I really really really like it I'm
so into it not spawn this is not
sponsored this is just our there's a
rental - goodness I've actually had a
bunch of friends that have cheese I know
every time on today I'm like like I know
I know honestly it's been on my mind on
your mind I have another SUV on my mind
you know we have to rent because three
people Suzy's driving separate but like
Maddie has so much stuff he could give
it to pages and all his toys have been
ugly your dog no chips me to the bomb
yes like I let me chips we're going to
bonds
we do we have to get firewood found
Starbucks without a pail of shoes on a
Dollar Tree we really wanted to stay
somewhere that was kind of like secluded
and away from things but we sort of
ended up not doing that which is
probably that's a good thing we're good
really here for like brand-new what have
we got what have we got hot chocolate we
need it
what kind of we want we want chocolate
mocha yes get it we're gonna be milk or
water yeah I don't
right now we're buying a log how many
logs we need me to check it this will
box
well how many logs you need and I don't
make fires often let's just get this box
of log help you know back in my day our
dad used to cut the trees oh my gosh put
the logs there it's true Maddie are you
being a ham for the camera that's not
your pee that's someone else's Maddie
are you being a ham are you getting up
on all your legs
let's do hands hands hands good boy give
me those hands Suzy's on her way with
sumo he's a massive bulldog he's
probably about like 80 pounds now he's a
huge pup so he is Maddie is 7 pounds you
are 7 pounds sumo is 75 no you probably
can could you smell it all the smells
did you eat your pasta that we got you I
fell asleep
it's okay you're gonna love it this
sleep sitting up I thought you guys were
head gone head they offer two hours nope
we'll wait were we after you said that
smiley face like I was so confused it's
like does that mean like they're almost
home no and then I went back and check
the time standing you guys are not only
being awfully 50 minutes yep we got all
the goods hey where are you are you
huffing and puffing over there
oh I love this song wait why is it
stopping
why does it stop nope I want everyone to
hear it hey guys what do we do now
we're Suzy just in traffic we got our
birthday cake her birthday was like last
month it wasn't the end of it slide it
back I say we just leave it like that
should you put in the fridge
[Music]
okay I can control my seven pound dog so
this is amazing he's so awesome Mady
he's gonna be just me it's a new
apartment yeah okay but he's gonna lose
his mind
oh well time for bed
we had a fun day traveling and tomorrow
we're gonna hike and do some fun stuff
so I'll see you tomorrow or whenever I
actually post my books oh my little
kinds of stuff so what words only you
guys can't actually see what I'm singing
but Thursday's happening